y en directo Vamos hasta ciudad de
México con nuestro corresponsal Mario
carbonel para hablar del pedido del
presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador quien solicitó demostrar si el
expresidente Felipe Calderón fue
beneficiario de los negocios de Genaro
García Luna Quién fue su secretario de
seguridad entre 2006 y 2012 y está
siendo juzgado en Estados Unidos por
delitos de narcotráfico Mario muy buenas
noches cuéntenos amlo siempre ha sido o
siempre ha sostenido que es
prácticamente imposible que un
presidente no esté enterado de lo que
hace en su subalternos ahora con las
acusaciones a Felipe Calderón parece
haber cambiado su postura qué
argumentado el mandatario al respecto
Así es López Obrador siempre ha dicho
que no hay manera que no se entere el
presidente de las cosas importantes en
el caso de Felipe Calderón y García Luna
siempre ha dicho que pues era su mano
derecha era un funcionario muy cercano
no obstante en efecto al parecer Pues
matizado un poco esta postura Al haber
dicho esta mañana que debe esperar hay
que esperar a que el juicio concluya y
que en todo caso se tiene que demostrar
que Calderón sabía de los negocios
ilícitos con el ampa que supuestamente
tenía Genaro García Luna ha dicho que a
su consideración hay tres escenarios
posibles el primero que todo esto que se
le imputa García Luna sea falso y en ese
caso no tendría a Felipe Calderón
absolutamente nada que temer en el
segundo escenario sería que si hubiera
hecho negocios ilícitos pero que
Calderón no estuviera enterado
y la tercera posibilidad es
evidentemente que si supiera Calderón de
los negocios si estuviera implicado para
esto Dijo insistió en que hay que
esperar y que lo que se le hace raro es
que también las agencias estadounidenses
no estén declarando que los vínculos que
pudo haber tenido García Luna y que la
DEA probablemente estaba enterada de ese
asunto y en ese sentido dice que falta
mucho por aclarar en este juicio Mario
cuéntenos Cómo ha sido la postura de
amlo respecto a la cobertura que ha dado
la prensa mexicana sobre el juicio de
García Luna
y presidente ha expresado su
inconformidad a su parecer no se le está
dando la cobertura que debiera tener el
mandatario dice que los medios no no
reflejan en sus portadas en sus primeras
planas este escándalo en ese sentido
bueno está de cierta forma diciendo que
no se le está registrando como posible
culpable a García Luna e incluso ha
hecho una tanda de revisión de las
primeras planas este día para demostrar
como no ha sido la nota de ocho columnas
como a su juicio debiera ser también
considera que hay una pues serie de
columnistas que tratan según el López
Obrador de defender a García Luna por el
hecho de que están cuestionando la
legitimidad de los testimonios el la
veracidad de los Testigos puesto que no
hay nada probado hasta el momento y es
solamente de oídas y de dichos